Fragrant butter pilaf Inarizushi
[music] Worked with [music]
Mostly, but I
can't live in Aburage I think
it's going to be a lot of rough stuffed
impact Kuroyuki big e Narizushi is originally
important to contrast armor and burage with refreshing vinegared rice
No matter how you think about it, if you travel together, you'll end up becoming an air pirate The theme of this time won't work just by pushing butter to the front What kind of answer will you find there
?
While it is juicy,
the umami of the ingredients continues to overflow like a fountain without feeling heavy along the lines.
Above all, it's made with soy
milk and kirimochi, and it's a white sauce that makes you feel good
.  The light flavor unique to the sauce
was essential, after it was
born, and then sprinkled with several types of cheese on top before being baked in the oven
.
I'm ascertaining the last minute increase to the maximum.
But it doesn't lighten the
greasyness.The ingredients are strong and can claim the deliciousness.In
contrast to Satomei Saito's heavy people, they are cruel and
attack from all directions.sai
[music]
r